[Musique]
dans la
dépendance je l'ai rencontrée pour la première fois j'étais tout de
suite amoureux
[Musique]
comment tu allais
[Musique
] dès que je l'ai vue j'ai eu
immédiatement peur de la perdre
quand as-tu rechuté
[Musique]
donc
les 64 000  la question est ce qu'il y a dans la
valise
[Musique]
il y a une différence entre ce que vous
pensez que vous devriez vouloir et ce que vous
voulez réellement
vous êtes ma nouvelle personne préférée
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que j'aurais l'air si sexy
enceinte noddy s'il vous plaît ne tombez pas
enceinte
attendez  pourquoi ressembles-tu à ça pourquoi
c'est comme une musique country dans le bon sens
ou dans le mauvais sens [ __ ] tu ferais mieux de plaisanter
Je secoue le sentiment qu'il
y a quelque chose que vous ne me dites pas que
vous êtes comme une sorte de relation de fille,
vous pouvez tous me juger si vous
voulez mais je m'en fiche je n'ai jamais
été aussi heureux oh vous tous allons-y  nue en
ce moment
je t'aime
j'ai toujours été avec
toi avant que tu sois b
orn jusqu'à après
ton départ